So, what happens on the next step,
all right?
Well, the first thing that
happens is we resample.
By the way, we're going to go
through the exact algorithm of this
in a little bit.
To resample what we do is we
first randomly pick a particle
from this top distribution.
This is the distribution we had
after the multiplication, right?
And of course the, the bigger
the weight the more likely we'll pull
out a particle,
that's what these weights mean.
So we're more likely to find things
here than say over here for two reasons.
One, there's just more particles over
here, than over here, or to the right,
than on the left.
And also those particles
have a higher weight.
They have a bigger value.
So I sample the particles, and
every new particle that it creates
starts off with a uniform weight.
So I just, let's say I need
1000 particles, 1000 times,
I, I might get the same particle
more than once, that's okay.
Then what I do is I,
I sample and I move.
Now, what do you mean, move?
Well, remember those actions,
the use, okay?
So if I, if the robot thinks it took
a step two meters to the right, okay?
It shifts that particle by two meters.
It shifts its belief of
where it is two meters.
And then finally,
it adds a little bit of noise.
This is just like we were doing
with the common, remember?
You start off with a distribution.
You do the deterministic shift,
and then you add some noise.
Well our, to do our distribution, we
first have to sample our particles, then
do the deterministic shift, then we,
add a little bit of uncertainty to that.
Okay, so here you can see the resulting
thing is we have a density that has been
resampled, so
there's like a whole bunch of points.
And shifted with a little
uncertainty added in.